my name is Toby Arden and in my humble
opinion mainstream fashion brands still
make women of color feel invisible nude
lipsticks nude colored nails new dresses
even nude underwear stays fashionable
season after season but news seems to me
weird shades of pink of multiple shades
of beige people often women that look
like me don't fit the fashion and beauty
industries idea of what a nude should be
[Music]
let's face it I'm over deep Brown than a
honey beige and I'm not alone in needing
a brown rather than a pink when it comes
to finding the right shade of nude I'm
not creating new products the Messier
complexion of black women women of color
not only a mainstream fashion brands
losing business but they're telling
women that looks like me that we don't
matter that we don't exist of course
there are bigger problems than me find a
bra that matches the complexion of my
skin but it does highlight how little
the fashion and beauty industries values
black skin by not creating diverse
products to cater to customers it shows
why we're still battling for diversity
on the runways and on magazine covers it
seems that the fashion and beauty
industries only work to serve the needs
of white women and white women only
however some independent fashion and
beauty brands have taken charge and
tried to create new products for women
of color yes the beauty industry signs
put women of color in their campaigns
and it is starting to make new products
for women of darker skin tones and yes
changes happen but we can't just rely on
smaller beauty and fashion brands
high-end and high street brands need to
make sure that all women of color has an
option when it comes to buying nude so
right now it's got the brown we're nuns
leave my white chocolates invisible it's
me so let's champion Browns you've got
women of color feel visible